ακολουθούμε εσί στην εκδήλωση διαμαρτηα στο φδι πόστημα και τα ξετεθεωρισα ότι ήταν και επικίνδυνη
για τα παιδιά να το πάρω έτσι και ωσμητέρα και ως εκπαιδευτικός καιως υπουργός ίπα
ότι πως είναι δυνατόν να ανίγουμε αυτόν το δρόμο στα παιδιά όχι απλά της παρανομίας
αλλά και τις επικινδυνότητας σε κεί είναι την ώρα νεκμίς μία παρά να ξεκινήσουν απόλες
τις πόλης να έρχονται στην πλατία ενελευθερίες τα πάρα πολεπικίνδυνο κι αυτό και βγάλαμε εμείς
στην ανακίνωση όποιος και να ήταν αυτός πυ του τους παρότριείναι ο πάκαραλισμίπου χαρικάτεση αγωικά
με την αποτι χα χις εκδηλώσες ήμουν περήφανει δε χαρει κάπλά εμουν περήφανη για τα
παιδιά διαβάζοντας την απάντηση τις ψένιπα μπράβο μπράβο γιατί όχι επειδή είναι οι διοφιδίας η
το οποιος δήποτε άλλος οποιαδίποτε άλλη πρόκληση προς το σχολείο το σχολείο πρέπει να ανεθορακισμένο
και αν τα παιδιά έχουν αυτές τις δεξιότητες να κρίνουν και μάλιστα να να ορθόνουν
το παράστημα τους και να λέναι όχι σε αυτές τις προκλήσεις έχουμε να απόψεις εμείς
και θα τις δούμε και είναι παιδιά που διαφωνούν μαζί μου σε αυτό αρά αυτό
το χάρικα πάρα πολύ καιπραγματικά τους το ίπα είμαι πολύ περηφανεί αυτός ία στα σχολία
και μπούληνα είναι πολύ μεγάλον το θένωκαρησηκκαταγράφονται πως τοβιώνεται πως το παρακολουθίτεσης και τα ξεδεδό
θα είμαι πολύ ξεκάθαριγια πάρα πολλά χρόνια του είχαμε δει πολύ λαθασμένα το αφήσαμε αναλώνναμεδυνάμεις
κονδίλια προσπάθειες με λάθο τόχο των αέρχεση στα δεκαξει και τα δεκά εφτάνα κάπνεις παρεμβατικά
προγράμματα είναι να επιβάλλεις πινές δεν τολύ στο πρόβλημα πρέπει να δώσεις έμφαση στην πρόληψη
και τούτι η πρόληψη γίνεται αποδεδειγμένα πια και ερευνητικά από την προσχολική εκπαιδευψη αραβάλαμε προγράμματα
αποπέρσει στα νυπιαγωγία σε συνεργασία με εβανεπιστήμια κα